if you're a politician a lobbyist or an
insider and you're in the mood to party
check out a washington DC mansion called
the Sewell Belmont house you can ride a
mechanical bull meet the cow pie queen
and celebrate the state of Wyoming at
the cow pie barbecue Senator Chuck
Schumer is loving this thousand-dollar a
plate fundraiser and Robert Redford is
all smiles at this party look John
McCain and Nancy Pelosi are there to the
soul Belmont house is one of the most
popular places in Washington for events
I mean host fundraisers political
fundraisers lots of people have weddings
and receptions there so you might be
surprised to learn this your tax dollars
help fund this hot spot for Washington
insiders it's true says Lesley Page of
citizens against government waste over
the last ten years Sewell Belmont has
got a 3.4 million dollars in earmarks
call it earmarks pork or bringing home
the bacon politicians can't resist
directing taxpayer money to their
political supporters 1.9 million dollars
for a water taxi at 1.8 million dollars
to study swine odor reporters often
highlight the most ridiculous examples
but politicians have gotten good at
making pork sound uncontroversial or
even appealing they always sound apple
pie patriotism children the senior
citizens or museums museums are one of
the biggies because they sound so good
part of the Sewell Belmont house serves
as a museum that highlights women
struggle for political equality who
could be against a museum especially a
museum about women's rights and equality
the likeness of Alice Paul adorns the
Sewell Belmont house she was a tireless
champion for female equality and the
inspiration for the prestigious Alice
award given by the Sewell Belmont house
to honor prominent women like senator
Mary Landrieu of Louisiana it's nice
that she got the award but it's not
appropriate for her to then turn around
and give taxpayer money to the stool
Belmont house two years after receiving
her award land
gave the Sewell Belmont house a very
special award a million-dollar earmark
if senator landrieu really really loves
the school bell my house she could have
also given her own money the Sewell
belmont house shouldn't need extra
revenue from government it should make
its revenue either from the museum or by
hosting receptions congressman jeff
flake of Arizona is one of the few
politicians who does not dole out pork
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
Arizona I thank the chairman flake has
embarked on a lonely battle against
waste one piece of pork at a time
whether it's a teapot museum in North
Carolina or the rock and roll hall of
fame in Ohio Congress keeps voting
against flakes attempts to chop pork
spending those opposed say no opinion
the chair the noes have it and the
amendment is not adopted but he keeps
trying to pass amendments to cut
earmarks how many of them have been
successful not one I came to the floor
39 times and was beaten like a rented
mule every time even fellow Republicans
beat him like a rented mule for his
anti-pork stance in 2006 GOP leaders
kicked him off the Judiciary Committee
for bad behavior bad behavior was
speaking out it wasn't getting these
questionable earmarks that have a couple
of our members actually in jail right
now I know that I will forfeit my
freedom my reputation my worldly
possessions members like congressman
randy Duke Cunningham who entered prison
the same year flake got booted from the
Judiciary Committee the Duke Cunningham
case was a poster child for why pork is
bad Cunningham used earmarks this year
business to defense contractors who in
turn lavished him with money and gifts
over a million in cash antique persian
rugs furniture use of a yacht club fees
a rolls-royce and vacation expenses the
Duke Cunningham earmarks camp and the
subsequent criminal action against him
was a wake-up call to a lot of members
of Congress that made them very skittish
you're marking plummeted after the
Cunningham scandal but old habits die
hard and politicians quickly returned to
their pork lovin ways and absolutely we
need earmark reform and when I'm
president I will go line
line to make sure that we are not
spending money unwisely that's why
earmarks reimbursed as a big issue in
the 2008 presidential election we had
hoped that President Obama because of
what he said during the election would
be tougher on earmarks but port politics
have continued to sizzle under the Obama
presidency spending on pork swelled
fourteen percent from 2008 to 2009 and
when it comes to bringing home the bacon
guess who's emerged as one of the best
when reports surface she had been swayed
with a 100 million dollar Medicaid deal
just for Louisiana she bragged it was
actually 300 million the 300 million
dollar earmark is now called the
Louisiana Purchase because of suspicions
that have purchased Landrieu support for
the president's health care bill I
didn't know I was going to vote for the
bill until the very end men pioneered
pork barrel politics but senator
Landrieu proves that female politicians
are equally skilled at bringing home the
bacon they are now doing what the big
guys do is that the kind of political
equality suffered just fought for I make
no apologies for leading this effort
pork barrel spending is not equal in
fact it is the opposite of equal it's an
unfair unaccountable process where Hugh
is the most powerful gets the most
earmarks senator Landrieu and the
director of the Civil Belmont house told
us they were unavailable to be
interviewed for this piece but just to
show there are no hard feelings I hope
you'll donate to the Sewell Belmont
house but only if they agree to stop
accepting pork payments for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie
get what you want
you can give
you